the number of Chicago residents living
more than a mile away from a grocery
store has jumped by 63 percent since
2013. the Liberals are blaming the
growing food desert on The Usual
Suspects racism
discrimination
inequality in fact the problem is crime
shoplifting and vandalism as one Walmart
representative told the New York Post
quote collectively our Chicago stores
have not been profitable since we opened
the first one nearly 17 years ago so
what is Chicago going to do about it are
Chicago officials going to arrest the
criminals no of course not
they're going to open government-owned
grocery stores instead that is the
proposal by Chicago mayor Brandon
Johnson to address the food desert
crisis